what's up guys
bandit here have you ever been just
adventuring across hyrule you know doing
normal stuff
picking up herbs oh look a chicken
nugget
killing bokoblins and generally having a
good time when you come across
a giant skull sitting in the middle of
mud
well that's what this video is all about
the bottomless swamp is the area in
question and there are so many weird
things going on here that for over four
years now there really hasn't been a
theory made on it
leaving several huge questions
unanswered such as
is it a real skull why is it here and
where did it come from
well let's start by pointing out all
this weird stuff and then we'll come to
a conclusion based on what we find
as previously mentioned the skull is
sitting in the middle of
mud the likes of which neither link nor
the monsters in the area can swim in
and speaking of monsters the skull is
filled with them and acts as a large
bokoblin camp
there are the weird limestone-esque
rocks jutting out along the sides of the
mud pool
there are a bunch of dead trees in the
area and there are incomplete skull rock
carvings halfway down the hill
one of which has a loner low level
bokoblin just sitting inside and the
other of which has a beam through its
eye for some reason
and the weirdest of all this really
weird stuff is the fact that it's
surrounded
by ganon's malice but yet even though
there's so much going on here
strangely there's no shika shrine
present lots to unpack here for sure
but let's start with the most obvious of
them all the skull itself
the material used for the skull is
pretty interesting as you can see from
these screenshots taken at the same time
of day
one being the giant skull and the other
being one of the bakoblin camp skulls
located halfway down the hill
the material used for the giant skull
has a different crack pattern to it and
is a slightly different color
also within the cracks on the surface of
the giant skull you can see that the
inside of the skull is actually a little
bit
lighter and a little bit warmer of a
color than what's on the surface
this is also visible from the parts of
the skull that are broken like the
broken horn sitting in the mud this
material is completely unique to the
giant skull and does not appear
anywhere else in the game so the
immediate question we have to ask
is is this giant skull made of rock or
is it actual bone
now there's actually a very simple way
to answer this question that
previously i didn't really think about
doing but have since been
enlightened if we comb through the
game's object file names
like i did with this map by mr cheese
that took forever because there's no
area search option meaning i had to
guess names one by one until coming
across the right one we can actually see
the name of the giant skull
object it's listed as fld obj
underscore enemy base rock underscore a
underscore zero
one clearly the developers of breath of
the wild knew that this was a
rock so we already have an easy answer
for that question that
immediately removes any speculations
about monsters from times past that the
skull could have come from
admittedly it's a little disappointing
however we still have plenty of
questions that need answers even if the
giant skull isn't an
actual skull if this giant skull is in
fact made of rock
then what rock was it made from as i
detailed more in a previous video about
the breach of demise
i personally believe that this jutting
yellowish rock that only appears in a
few places of the game
is a kind of limestone or other
sedimentary rock
that oftentimes formulates underneath
the surface of the ground
for these rock shards to be exposed like
this and the giant skull to be located
in the middle of them i think the answer
is staring us in the face
it was carved from this limestone-ish
rock right here
giving a reason for the lighter color on
the inside as for who carved the skull
out of the rock i think that answer is
also pretty obvious
i mean it is filled with members of
ganon's army so probably them
mccobbins are also well known for having
carved out the bakoblin camp skulls
which is what i believe this low-level
loner down here was doing before you
know being killed by link
the pool of mud that formed around the
giant skull probably did so
because of the crater-like shape left in
the ground as a result of all the
carving
in fact if we test the depth of this
mudpool in-game using magnesis to lower
a metallic object into it we can
actually see that it's not bottomless
at all it's maybe 15 to 20 feet deep at
the most
and the result of the shallow dirt and
debris filled rainwater basin
is a bunch of mud that's just too thick
to swim in and because
everything in this area that we can see
today would have been essentially
created by ganon's monsters that would
explain why there's no shrine in the
area as the entire hillside that we see
today
didn't really exist like this back when
the sheikah created all that shika stuff
now onto the biggest question of this
entire theory
why why did these blinds randomly decide
to make a big
scary giant monster skull when their
other smaller scary giant skulls have
worked just fine for the rest of them
across hyrule
the answer i believe lies in a nearby
goopy substance
and i don't mean the mud you see
strangely as i pointed out earlier
ganon's malice is abundant in this area
right beside the mud pool and on a lot
of the limestone actually
most fans are very familiar with the
substance by now and one thing that most
people agree on regarding malice is the
fact that it is most likely
sentient or an extension of ganon's will
this is proven by several things such as
the fact that we can see eyes in the
mellis that can search out an attack
link or the fact that it uses its more
solidified portions to block out
important passageways from the hero that
it must have deduced were important
and of course there is the fact that it
can possess and control the sheikah
technologies and inanimate skeletons of
deceased enemies
because of this we can assume that
malice is where malice wants to be
where it chooses to be and it's choosing
to be right here
right beside this random giant monster
rock carving of a skull
and after thinking through countless
possibilities i would like to present to
you the most
possible explanation in my opinion what
if the blinds were commanded by ganon to
construct a
giant stall monster for ganon to possess
using his malice according to creating a
champion the form of calamity ganon we
fight at the end of the game had only
begun to be created after link woke up
in the present day
so are we really supposed to believe
that ganon just sat still with zelda for
the past 100 years without a single
backup plan
all the way until link resurrected i
mean technically his
ultimate plan to unleash the power of
the shika to take over the world kind of
failed 100 years ago when zelda
discovered she could just poof them away
at will
so what if ganon concocted a different
plan
one that enabled him to complete his
destruction of hyrule as a giant
monster while zelda was busy keeping his
main consciousness sealed in the castle
i don't think the fact that the giant
skull is made of rock is much of a
problem for this theory
we can clearly see at other points in
the franchise that inanimate objects are
more than capable of being possessed so
i am completely positive that ganon has
the power to possess an inanimate object
such as a carved rock monster fossil if
he wanted to
one last thing to point out about this
theory though would be something
specific that zelda says in the english
version of the game that many fans have
taken
a huge issue with after calamity ganon
is defeated at the hands of link
he re-materializes as dark beast ganon
out in hyrule field
while we are watching this happen zelda
says that he has given up on
reincarnation and assumed his pure
enraged form
the reason why fans hate this segment of
dialogue so much is that it pretty much
differentiates entirely from the
japanese version of the game
which roughly translates to zelda saying
instead that this form was born from his
obsessive refusal to give
up on revival the clear discrepancy
between the two versions of what is
supposed to be the same piece of
dialogue is at first glance just a huge
mistake on the english translations part
but wait back up seriously you're
telling me that in 2017
the biggest zelda game of all time with
the biggest budget of all time
was released with a glaring mistake that
was written
reviewed and voice acted in what is
probably the most climactic experience
of the entire game
i mean i guess it's possible but what if
it's not so much that it's just
blatantly incorrect
but rather that it's referring to
something the japanese version was
not if you think about it it's a bit
strange to say
right after link literally beats this
incarnation of calamity ganon to death
that ganon gave up on reincarnation he
was defeated actually which is why the
japanese version just essentially says
that he refuses to die
so what if the english version is
referring to the giant
monster skull that garen was trying to
use as his next
incarnation what if it was almost ready
and his malice was moving into position
for possession but before his plan could
fully come to fruition a hero decided to
awaken
foiling his plans and forcing ganon to
give up on reincarnation
of course this is just my theory though
what do you guys think was the
unexplained
giant rock skull in the middle of the
not so bottomless swamp being crafted
for ganon's possession
in his period of not doing anything else
for a hundred years or is it still an
enigma
forever unexplained until further notice
let me know in the comments below hey
guys thank you so much for watching if
you would be so kind as to leave a like
below on this video it would greatly
assist in getting this video spread
around to fans just like you and me and
hey with e3 literally next month
we need to start building that hype and
speaking of which make sure you
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
done so already so that you can stick
around for all that content to come next
month
and beyond huge huge thanks to my bandit
crew of which i have a new
masked bandit level supporter to
announce say hello to
james w who just joined at the top level
james
seriously thank you and more hellos go
to bobo and tyrol g
who have also generously joined up with
my elite crew if you watching are
interested in being a part of my
community and helping these videos come
to life feel free to check out that blue
join button located below or the links
to my patreon and merch pages in the
description below also down there are
the links to my social media pages so
please come follow me there if you want
updates on
the real life gannon yes i named him
ganon that's all i've got for you in
this one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is
masentanovanit looking forward to seeing
you in the next one and signing out
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you